mike i asked you like i asked my twitter
followers last night
what did you say
in the moment when bam adabayo blocked
jayson tatum if you can repeat it on
television what did you say
exactly what you're thinking but i
stopped i stopped cussing a while ago
man i stopped cussing
but you know
i was like give me that i mean i i
yelled i yelled so i thought i was up
yes is the whole house
does
yes like give me that and i look and i
have never blocked the shot like that in
my life at least not that i could recall
michael you said i was like
yes i i was so hyped and i am
and i don't have a dog in this fight i
wasn't rooting for anything either but
man i
it was it was as exciting
to fight what i do have a dog in the
fight but i still was a great plot i'm
saying oh me though yes i do
but i didn't put money on this either i
didn't bet on this one yeah but yeah
that was a that was a great play and you
know keep in mind because you're not
thinking about it in the moment you see
tatum going to the basket and you've
seen tatum you know he's dunked on
lebron famously in game seven
so he's dunked on people
he and jaylen brown they'll get you
now jaylen brown's dunked on giannis so
he saw him driving to the basket like oh
he's about to get another one
adebayo is right-handed
look at that people that's what the left
people look wait wait and that's that's
over the rim
look at that the ball is in the basket
and it's almost as if he reached in the
basket and took it out of the basket
first before we talk about the
brilliance of the block though i want to
go back to tatum
was it a mistake and look it it's
happening in real time okay so it's like
i'm not trying to you know get but and
the lane was over like you said he's
here no people know was it a mistake to
try to dunk that like that is that it
did the dunk
allow him to make the block a lot of
people are saying if you wouldn't have
tried to yam on him you wouldn't have
got blocked what you gonna do what you
gonna do like you you okay i think you
go finger roll
florida i don't know off the glass i
don't know yeah i got you it's
the best dunks now take go to those old
school dunk old old-school dunkers
dominique wilkins you know you know
those guys they would get it's violent
they go in there it's just like whom
they throw that's why they say punching
in it you punch it in yeah
so that's the best play i don't want to
be throwing this up off the glass i
don't want to be thinking i got you i'm
just i'm just going there
because he's done that before give you
know why he got blocked because that was
a great play by adebayo and 99 times out
of 100 he's going to make that dunk
yeah but you know i got to get great
play about
no you got to get props all right let's
talk we'll talk about the brilliance of
the block but i gotta sneak in a quick
sidebar quick sidebar
one of the reasons i hate the nba draft
process
is how people always talk about oh it's
a weak draft or they talk about how
man if you don't if you're not in the
lottery or if you don't get one of those
top picks you're not getting a a a
impact player or a game-changing player
if that wasn't a game-changing play i
don't know what was damn autobio
14th pick of the draft okay
already an all-star okay so
we just talked about nikola joker second
round pick so miss me with the whole oh
man guess that's it for the draft we
can't find nobody the good franchises
constantly find players no matter where
they're picking in the draft so props to
the heat for developing bam out of bio
props to him for evolving into the
player that he's been such a good player
that he can now
be in the conversation
for one of the greatest defensive plays
we've seen in postseason history as a
matter of fact one urban magic johnson
yeah no stranger to hear this no
straight no yeah no stranger to
hyperbole
on twitter
tell me about tweeted last night what'd
you
this is the first magic said that bam by
the bio's block was the greatest
defensive play he's ever seen in the
playoffs magic in general last night was
on fire magic last twi twitter magic
johnson had his uh he had his game six
and 1980 twitter performance last night
was the greatest twitter night in magic
johnson's career between this
and going in on the clippers which we'll
get to in a second we'll get back to
that in a second magic johnson had a a
phenomenal night was this the greatest
defense i'll ask i'll just ask you
neutrally open-ended oh nice that's a
yes or no question what is this the
greatest defensive play no simple no
okay why not no
no it wasn't why not which and why not
what it was
okay
this is game one of the eastern
conference finals
right
game one so this is a block that won the
game that sealed the win they were
already up
he sealed the win
i think we saw didn't we just see the
greatest block in nba it wasn't that
long ago
okay we had color tv air conditioning
way back then way back what when the
cavaliers
erase a 3-1 deficit
against the greatest team 20 2016. yeah
the block greatest team
regular season team in nba history the
73 win warriors
lebron james andre iguodala game seven
a chase down block
that was huge that's the greatest
defensive play i've ever seen magic was
there magic where was you
no i'm with you
it's hard to top look that that play is
so cold until it's called the block and
everybody knows what you're talking
about like is that we're not talking
about another one
it's just the block no it is that's
right from us great play great great
block last night but the greatest nba
history that's just ridiculous
well wait a minute though wait a minute
though this is actually this is this is
number two for me and i think we need to
distinguish we need to make a
distinction i agree with you on the
block but not just because of the stakes
and the significance i agree with you on
the block because i mean lebron came
from
god knows how far of a distance to chase
down our
it and then he pulls with it with the
outstretched arms after he pinned it on
the backboard i can watch that over and
over man i can watch
number three for me is lebron on tiago
splinter in 2013 number three another
good one and
and here and here's why i would put this
one in in that mix and right now i'm a
person at a moment but so be it at
number two i'm not talking about the
stakes i'm not talking about the
situation i'm not talking about the
stage of the postseason
i'm strictly just talking about from a
skill and from a play
perspective just the degree of
difficulty if you will
i mean this is not this is not without
due respect tiago splitter this is not a
scrub
this is not the knicks converging on
again with all due respect charles smith
this is one of the rising stars in the
nba if not already a star in jason
taylor
i mean he's putting record-setting
numbers this is a guy who's yammed on a
lot of people he has banged on a bunch
of people in the postseason and for bam
out of bio to meet him at the rim and
send him home
that's that's one of the
magic as it goes far magic will name 50
managers in the mvp conversation in one
tweet but he didn't go too far this time
this was one of the best players plays
i've ever seen one of the best players
no no no you say you you said it the
right way you said one of the best plays
sure the best play
he's ever seen
i don't think so i think i think magic
and all the time it was magic in the
finals like nine times with the lakers
he's in the finals nine times
now he did some damage and he had some
damage done against him he had some
great players he went up against
remember jordan pippen rodman yeah with
the pistons he's seen some great players
now come on i'm sure some no but
generally speaking though michael
magic was on fire on twitter last night
as all of lakers twitter was
you